There's only one thing I can teach
you.
Red Archer
Barbatospachi or
[music]
Barbatoske Family Ability A hundred
weak beasts, keep
shooting arrows that will surely
hit as long as you can concentrate, once a day is the
limit.
There
are only three people who shoot and do all kinds of beasts, the leader and the president. The
leader and the president.
There was someone who came What kind of
action demons
The bow of concentration and patience is the devil's gate No
matter how far away the enemy is, you can kill your allies and save your allies
If you have an archer,
missions will change completely It's a feared weapon
.  It's
impossible,
it's not
suitable for demons.
Then I'll give you the assignment